[Music]
a campus drenched in sunset hues colors
radiating like flame at first glance
this painting may appear to be an
impossible abstract image but a closer
look reveals the tender stems lush
petals and velvety texture of a canna
lily this metamorphosis of natural
subjects into abstract geometry is
commonplace in the work of Georgia
O'Keeffe the revolutionary American
painter and sculptor but the magic
behind this transformation remains just
as elusive as the artist herself born in
Wisconsin in 1887 O'Keeffe spent her
childhood plucking wild flowers and
arranging fruits to paint at 17 she
moved to Chicago to study at the
prestigious Art Institute her teachers
trained her to faithfully reproduce
reality in the conventions of European
masters although she enjoyed the
solitude and precision of this work
O'Keeffe felt little personal connection
to it
after moving to New York she was
increasingly drawn to the clean lines
striking composition and vivid colors of
Japanese art
o'keefe soon found a teacher whose
lessons inspired her to put those
interests into practice unlike her
previous teachers Arthur Wesley Dao
urged his students to focus on more
abstract representations of light shape
and color these lessons manifested in
O'Keefe's
first series of abstract drawings
rendered in charcoal they present a
series of undulating lines bold shading
and billowing clouds these drawings defy
easy classification suggesting but never
quite matching any specific natural
reference earlier European painters in
the Cubist tradition had employed rigid
geometry to abstract external subjects
but here O'Keefe employed the shapes and
rhythms of nature to capture her
internal feelings experiments like these
would soon become a cornerstone of an
artistic movement called
American modernism although no single
style defines modernist painting its
proponents shared a desire to challenge
the realist traditions that dominated
art education beginning in the late
1910s modernist painting often used
geometric shapes and bold colors to
probe the American psyche
o'keefe threw herself into these
experiments but she was reluctant to
share her new work however when a friend
sent her charcoals to the art dealer
alfred stieglitz he became entranced in
1916 he arranged for a grand exhibition
in New York this marked the beginning of
a Keefe's career as a popular artist and
a relationship that would lead to
marriage in 1924 marriage didn't
diminish a Keith's taste for solitude
she traveled widely to teach and often
retreated to paint for months at a time
whether she was exploring the craggy
canyons of Texas the quiet forests of
South Carolina or the sun-bleached
desert of New Mexico her creative
process was based on ritual and close
observation she paid meticulous
attention to small details and spent
hours mixing paints to create exactly
the right colors when she found the
perfect hue she'd recorded in her
ever-growing collection of handmade
color cards O'Keefe also experimented
with perspective to celebrate objects
that were often overlooked in Rams Head
with hollyhock she places a weathered
skull and a delicate flower high above
the hills below this massive skull
overshadows the landscape casting both
the skeleton and the mountains and a new
eerie light
the public was captivated by her unique
perspective and secretive behavior she
was particularly praised for her massive
flower paintings ranging from fiery
poppies - ghostly calla lilies Stieglitz
and other critics of the time were
infatuated by 40 and psychology and were
quick to link these paintings to female
genitalia but O'Keeffe dismissed such
interpretations she resented the male
gaze that dominated the art world and
demanded her work be respected for its
emotional a vocation of the natural
world eventually O'Keefe settled down in
New Mexico near one of her favorite
artists retreats in her 70s her eyesight
began to fail but she continued to mine
the landscapes mysteries in new tactile
mediums O'Keefe kept creating until her
death in 98 and is remembered as the
mother of American modernism decades on
her work retains its wild energy and
O'Keeffe her personal mystique
[Music]
get to know the life of another
legendary artist Frida Kahlo and learn
more about the woman behind the
paintbrush with this video or explore
the art of jean-michel Basquiat one of
the most significant painters of the
20th century
[Music]